Film Courage: Can any book be made into a
movie?
Dr. Ken Atchity, Author/Producer: Any book?
Film Courage: Any book.
Dr. Atchity: No.
I don’t think so.
Like an instruction manual?
People have made instruction manuals into
movies?
But no, not any book.
But what makes the movie is absolute drama.
You have to have drama.
And I’m not talking about a bad movie, I’m
talking about a good movie that people will
not fast forward through or switch channels
on or to make a worthy movie a book has to
have drama and that means it has to have a
very clear three acts (beginning, middle and
end) and what defines the beginning is something
that hooks the audience into the story so
that it will not abandon the story and an
ending is something that makes you leave the
theater or turn off your television very satisfied
with the way the story ended whether it’s
happy or sad isn’t the point but satisfying
like the end of WITNESS where we realize that
the lovers cannot stay together even though
we want them to because it just wouldn’t
make any sense.
And the way the last shot is Peter Weir taking
a long time to let the car drive down the
lane away from the farm onto the road.
It’s such a long shot that it gives you
a chance to go through your head and think
“Oh c’mon, slow down, turn around, make
a U-turn or run after him.”
And none of that happens because your mind
is now going “That wouldn’t make any sense.
This is sad.
It’s got to end but it still was beautiful.”
But that’s good drama and good movie making.
But it’s the hardest part for any writer.
It has to be something that keeps you there
meaning filled with twists and turns and reversals
and unexpected events and so on that you don’t
want to tune out.
And if a book can do that, then it can be
a movie.
And if a book isn’t doing that but has potential
because it has a strong protagonist and a
strong antagonist that’s where a treatment
comes in.
You write a treatment and fix all the problems
with the book in the treatment and pitch the
treatment.
I’ve sold a number of movies based on a
treatment because the book had problems and
I almost wouldn’t let the buyers read the
book because once they said they want to do
it I go “Okay let’s just go with the treatment
please!”
But at the end they are ready to sign, they
have to look at the book and then they’ll
say “I see what you mean.”
But the treatment solves the problems.
You know if the middle is not dramatic enough.
Most especially the problem with novels is
the ending is not powerful enough and clear
enough.
The third act is not clear enough where you
see that there’s a turning point that goes
fro act two to act three.
Because editors in New York are not as demanding
as audiences are in a movie theater.
They don’t really look for turning points
the same way an audience does.
There are exceptions to all of this stuff.
None of it is rules but basically a three-act
structure needs to be there and has to be
dramatic.
All three acts have to be dramatic.
You have to have a protagonist that you can
relate to.
You don’t have to like her but you have
to relate to her.
And you have to have an antagonist who is
worth of her and is in every way as strong
as she is because otherwise the ending is
predictable.
And the stronger the antagonist, the stronger
the protagonist and the stronger the story
is.
So I hope that answers the question.
Books that have at least some of those elements
can be turned into movies.
I actually used to have a class that’s called
‘Designing Your Novel To Be A Film.’
Because the best place for that is on your
original drawing board.
Make sure that when you design your novel
that you include these things in your novel
and that way you won’t be disappointed when
nobody wants to make it into a film.